اهلا بكم ونتابع معكم الاجتماع الوزاري
الثاني بين دول العربيه ومجموعه جزر فاسفك
فهذه كلمه للامين العام للجامعه الدول
العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
مشتركه التقاء بين مصالحنا في مختلف
المجالات السياسيه والاقتصاديه والثقافيه
وغيرها من المجالات الهامه للجانبين
وتدرك جامعه الدول العربيه باهتمام تطلعات
ومخاوف دوركم الموقره ولقد قطعتم الاف
الاميال من منطقتكم صوب ومنطقتنا وهذا
انما يعكس حرصكم على تقريب وجهات النظر
ازاء القضايا المختلفه وتشارك وتشارك
الطموحات نحو مستقبل افضلا لدوالنا
وشعوبنا ونود ان نؤكد ان الجانب العربي
مستعد للتعاون معكم في مختلف المجالات ذات
الاهتمام المشترك والتي من بينها قضايا
تغير المناخ مثلما تحدثتم والاستجابه
للاوبئه والامن البحري وحمايه البيئه
والامن الصحي وكلها نقاط تحدثتم فيها ان
كلا كلا من المنطقتين العربيه
والباسيفيكيه تحتل مكانه جو استراتيجيه
هامه في ظل نظام الدوليه الحالي الامر
الذي يدعون الى ودعم التعاون جنوب جنوب من
اجل التعبير عن الاراده الحره والمستقله
لدولنا وشعوبنا وهنا اود ان اؤكد على
اهميه الدعم المتبادل بين الدول العربيه
ودول جزر الفاسفك في الموضوعات المطروحه
في الامم المتحده والمنظمات الدوليه فيما
يتعلق بالقضايا العادله للطرفين وكذلك
الدعم المتبادل للترشيحات للمناصب في
المناظر في المنظمات الدوليه ونحن مستعدون
لان نسمع من جانبكم المزيد حول قضاياكم
اسمحوا لي في هذا الاطار ان اطلعكم على
اخر التطورات والمستجدات على الساعه
العربيه
فان القضيه الفلسطينيه تقع على راس اجنده
الدبلوماسيه العربيه
وستواصل الدول العربيه حمل اللواء الدفاع
عن هذه القضيه في مختلف المحافل الدوليه
وفي مقدمتها الامم المتحده ونتطلع في هذا
الاطار الى تفهم دوركم الموقره لهذا المسح
العربي ودعمنا فيه ودعمنا فيه في الامم
المتحده وهنا ادعوكم للاستماع الى ابعاد
المشهد الراهب في فلسطين
والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه المتكرره من
معالي الوزير رياض المالكي وزير الخارجيه
وشؤون المغتربين بدوله فلسطين
ولذلك ولا زالت جامعه الدول العربيه تعمل
جاهده من اجل التوصل الى حلول سياسيه
للازمات العربيه الراهنه بما يحفظ
مقدراتها ووحداتها ووحدتها الترابيه
وسلامه مؤسساتها الوطنيه كما سنواصل العمل
من اجل اخلاء منطقه الشرق الاوسط من اسلحه
الضمار الشامل على غرار المنطقه الخاليه
في منطقه جنوب الباسيفيك
وعلى الصعيد التنمويه فان الدول العربيه
تضع مساله التنميه المستدامه على راس
اولوياتها في الوقت الرائع وسنعمل على
التنسيق مع دول جزر الباسيفك خاصه في ظل
في اطار الرؤى والمبادرات التنمويه
العربيه والتي من بينها رؤيه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه 2023
اخيرا الحضور الكريم نتطلع الى ان يفهم
اجتماعنا اليوم في وضع حجر اساس للتعاون
العربي الفلسفيكي في اطار مؤسسي يضمن
الاستدامه والتطور لهذا التعاون من خلال
العمل على ابرام وثقه تاسس لمنتدى التعاون
عربي باسيفيكي في مختلف المجالات المجالات
يتضمن اليات واضحه ذات دوريه انعقادا تضمن
عقد لقاءات منتظمه للمسؤولين من الجانبين
اجدد شكري وتقديري لحكومه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وزاره الخارجيه تحت قياده سمو
الامير فيصل بن فرحان الاستضافه هذا
الاجتماع متمنيا لاعماله النجاح والتوفيق
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شكرا معالي الامن العام على كلمتكم
الضافيه واعلن بذلك انتهاء مراسم افتتاح
الاجتماعي الوزاري المشترك الثاني بين
الدول العربيه والمجموعه الدول جزر وادعو
وسائل الاعلام للتفضل لمغادره القاعه
نستانف اعمالنا في جلسه العمل المغلقه
شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات